how were you introduced to the Alexander
technique I was introduced to it in 1969
I was working as as an actor and
training and my teacher Sonia Moore was
a director and a teacher of the
stanislavsky system
and one day she said
I have invited an Alexander technique
teacher
and we were all very excited we thought
that we might have to wear togas you
know I thought it had something to do
with Alexander the Great
to my surprise there was this small
woman that came in and she started
working with us in a silent sort of way
but she was asking us to move and be
aware of our bodies and um
and when she placed her hands on my neck
I'll never forget it
I took
the biggest breath
in a long time you know I had asthma as
a child so
she unlocked something inside of me and
it was so shocking
and exciting shocking exciting and
surprising that I could breathe like
that
but thank God she did that and I thank
God I went to that class it totally
changed my direction in my life
I I decided that I wanted to know what
this Alexander technique was
and I did
ever since that class I've I've never
stopped
where was the class San Francisco it was
in New York oh in New York oh yeah yeah
the school it was in uh yeah 1969 New
York City
but that was a fun time yeah yeah it was
it was it was
what is the Alexander technique the
Alexander technique is a form of
psychophysical re-education
and better said or more simply said it
has to do with you learning
about
using yourself better you know and you
learn to observe so the first big
principle that we use is awareness you
learn to become more aware of your
energy and how you use it right and you
also begin to understand how you
interfere
with your best use
so you know how what that means is if I
reach for this
card here if I'm collapsing just to pick
up a car that weighs nothing you know it
doesn't make sense that that's not the
best use right so you learn that you can
just Lane thin and you learn that you
can bring yourself a little bit forward
and just pick it up as lightly as you
can
like that if I were an athlete that
would mean that I can I can run faster
if I begin to use more Consciousness
more awareness that's the first
principle the second principle and and
probably more complicated is the idea of
slowing down
I call it I have time
so if I say to myself I have time
I can be okay
about stepping back a little bit and
taking care of myself
and in the process I can feel more
accurately what's going on in my body
and then I'm left left with a choice do
I want to continue using myself this way
or do I want to make some changes
you see so choice is part of this
technique
uh the third uh principle is that
there's a relationship between uh I
don't know if you can see it better if I
do it this way but there's a
relationship between your head
and your spine
and sometimes when we are not conscious
we tense our neck a little bit too much
which begins to pull your head back
and down and then the whole spine
collapses forward
and now I I'm having a really hard time
breathing
because I've just collapsed into my
diaphragm and my whole rib cage is
collapsing
and then I'm beginning to hold my hip
joint it's a system right
so you learn that this primary control
can change
how you organize yourself to go into
activities
I call it an Attunement
so you know if I compare it to music
playing music it would be the violinist
putting the violin on the shoulder
and
and tuning the instrument listening and
then making delicate shifts in the in
the tension of the string to get the
right pitch right I'm doing that with my
own body
you tune yourself up so then you can go
into your performance
free
I know it's it's a little crazy but
um and then we have a thing called
Direction
and Direction has a lot to do with the
organization you know that where you're
where you want your head to go and what
happens to the rest of the body
you see it's a way of talking to
yourself
you said something a mantra that you had
I have time yes what if you don't have
time but that's been part of your
calming technique so lovely question uh
yeah most people think that they have no
time
including myself sometimes we feel like
we're in a rush we have a lot to do we
have children and they're screaming we
have to take the dog uh on a walk
so the fact is we do and and we're not
saying that people should step back for
hours on end we're talking about just a
few seconds
just enough
so you can improve yourself
I'm going to make a compare an example a
really good example if you are seeing a
diver an Olympic diver
you will see the diver
going up you know to the diving board
and then when they reach the you know
the edge of the diving board they stop
they're saying I have time to organize
themselves
and then when they feel that they're
ready then they pushed and they dive
so it's a moment just to get it together
you see to get to gather all the energy
as one whole human being
I do that with actors
in fact I think I've become famous
because of that that I do that well that
they can you know be in us on a set with
a hundred people
right and they take the test a few
seconds
before they go and do the scene
what is rooting
um I think I know what you're talking
about you mean in terms of the FL of the
feet
okay so uh it is very important for all
of us
not just actors but everybody to have a
relationship with the Earth
in fact right now more than ever in our
history
of human history people are disconnected
with the Earth
so if you're disconnected
from your roots
you you make it up in the neck
so that's where that tension in the neck
comes from is that there's no Foundation
at the bottom so you compensate the lack
of balance
by tensing the neck you're literally
holding yourself
imagine doing a scene
where you need emotion and freedom to an
expression you can't express if you're
still holding the jaw and the neck
you're busy doing that and so the
character is not free the you know
characters need
freedom to express
you know so it is the actor's
responsibility
to find that freedom you know and of
course every character is different so
it demands different kinds of freedoms
why is the Alexander technique the most
efficient method to help you connect
with your body because you use it in the
act of living
uh so a lot of techniques you do have to
do exercises and procedures they're
usually called procedures
in the studio
and uh and they're a very small
um movements that you do with the breath
but you continually are doing them
um
disconnected from activities what what
was dramatic for me about Alexander and
Illuminating was that you did it as you
applied it to things that you would do
in life like standing bending
walking sitting
speaking singing and then you take it
into more complicated
activities that require skill or
artistry
so that is exciting but I've had one of
my first students in San Francisco was a
mailman
and I loved it because he had to do this
uh activity of walking and delivering
and uh repetitive very repetitive
activity and he had a back problems and
he would get tired and he was shy and he
had really bad skin
but you know what
he became so much better and through
through awareness and the process of the
Alexander technique and uh somehow he
got better in all these areas even his
skin started looking more clear I don't
know why but maybe he just was
more free you know
did he tell you why he wanted to take
the class uh yeah oh yeah he said that
if he did not study Alexander he was
going to look for medical help
he was in pain he was in pain so you
know lifting all that male bags and
stuff right
wow
what is one of your favorite stories on
how the Alexander technique has saved
someone's life or improved their life oh
I have many but one that I remember
I had this Japanese
older gentleman he was about 84 years
old
and he came with his son and he wanted
to walk again he had he had not been
able to walk
and uh and he looked into my eyes and he
said
I want to walk to my garden I have a
beautiful Japanese garden and I love
tending to the plants
and I would love to do that again
so uh we worked on that and I wasn't
really sure that I could actually help
him because he really was not walking at
all
and then uh about about five to six
months into our work together
after his lesson I said to him would you
like to go around the block with me
so we went out to the street and I
helped him
go around the block and he did
all by himself
and of course he went back to gardening
so that that was and now his son comes
for Alexander lessons